Baltimore removed Confederate monuments
overnight under the cover of darkness
the city is part of a growing movement
around the country is gaining momentum
after the white supremacist
demonstration in Charlottesville
Virginia that left one count of
protester dead crews in Baltimore took
down four monuments including a
prominent statue of generals robert e
lee and Stonewall Jackson Julianna
Goldman is there in Baltimore Julianna
good morning good morning
over night city workers and contractors
removed for Confederate statues from
across the city here we spoke with one
person who was here overnight they told
us it took three hours to remove statues
of robert e lee and Stonewall Jackson as
you can see behind me all that's left
now is a base covered in graffiti there
was a small crowd on hand here last
night and this decision came after the
Baltimore City Council passed a
resolution on Monday which was approved
by the mayor who said that she did this
in the middle of the night to avoid the
violent classic clashes in
Charlottesville this is all part of a
larger effort in cities nationwide but
particularly in the south to take down
these Confederate symbols elected
officials from Lexington Kentucky to
North Carolina to Birmingham Alabama are
ordering the removal of these statues in
Birmingham the mayor ordered the city to
board up the Confederate sailors and
soldiers monument now here at this site
people have been coming by all morning
people have been driving by honking and
cheering some of the people have been
coming by here are taking pictures some
in support of the moves overnight
others not so much all right thank you
very much Julianna